Studio
Google employees to protest today over
job losses and what unite calls union
busting
Sir Richard Branson satellite launching
firm virgin orbit files for bankruptcy
protection and puts itself up for sale
stuck in a 40-year Time Warp the
chairman of Marx and Spencer calls for
changes to company law
I've actually bought with me 10. this is
only 10 annual reports I don't know what
you can see these are all big company
annual reports they can hardly lift it
lovingly produced and full I have to
tell you a very important information
that practically nobody's ever read
plus tributes to Nigel Lawson the
architect of 1980s economic reforms
who's died at the age of 91.
[Music]
good morning this is Ian King live an
hour of business and economic use From
The Heart of the City
but later this morning employees of
Google will be staging a demonstration
outside the tech Giants UK headquarters
at London's King's cross it comes amid
what the United Union has described as
union busting Google announced in
January it was planning to make
redundant some 10 000 employees around
the world hundreds of whom are thought
to be based here in the UK will joining
me now is Matt Whaley he's a regional
officer at unite the union Matt morning
to you how many members do you have in
King's cross
well we have over a thousand members now
it's steadily grown since the redundancy
program was announced back in January
and do you enjoy recognition from Google
we don't at this stage
um it is an aspiration it's something a
lot of our members now feel is necessary
in part because they think Google has
lost a lot of its values in terms of how
it treats its employees
so talk to me about the the consultation
process obviously Google announced this
big redundancy process earlier in the
year what's it been like
okay well I mean the redundancy
announcement came out worldwide it's not
just the UK that's affected by the job
Cuts we saw a lot of people approaching
the union for support concerned about
their jobs concerned about how the
process would be handled and you know
we've tried to engage with it we've
tried to ensure that the employee reps
were trained properly because when a
union isn't recognized you you will let
representatives to do a consultation
we've given them support we've given
them training they've been a very good
Bunch actually they've made good
proposed counter proposals to Google try
to improve the process but unfortunately
we don't think Google's really bought
into this consultation it's been seen
more of of any convenience rather than a
requirement that you have to do and
something that can actually benefit the
staff and benefit the company to make
sure you're not making mistakes with the
process
yes in your statement you you actually
use the term union busting I mean is
Google not cooperating with Union reps
or allowing them to sit in in meetings
with affected employees
they're not and it's quite sad really
because I've dealt with Google for a
number of years now I've been into this
building behind us I've represented
members who've had quite serious issues
and you know relations have been cordial
they've been professional but you know
since the Union's grown in size
um they've shut the Reps out of the
redundancy meetings we've got a lot of
Staff who are quite stressed there are
still problems with the redundancy
process that have carried over from the
collective consultation because
questions haven't really been answered
around how employees have been grouped
or pooled and there's been some
questions about the selection criteria
now we did one Google I wrote quite
politely to Google asking them to engage
with the trade unions so we could try to
sort this out and try to ensure the
process was fair and both times I got
told you know you're not recognized
we're not talking to you and you know
the result of that is people have now
raised grievances
and Google is refusing to hear those
grievances on the basis of the acas code
now the acas code isn't what governs an
employee's right to raise agreements in
its entirety if there are problems with
a redundancy process the employer is
supposed to address them and if you
raise a grievance you are supposed to be
permitted to have a work you know to
have a union representative according to
you which the company you're refusing
and refusing to allow allow reps to it
to basically going on the meetings I've
even had situations where I've had
members crying to me in meetings where
in meetings I've had with them where the
employer is demanding doctor
certificates to make reasonable
adjustments now they'll they say Google
that they'll consider allowing you a
companion in these meetings
if it's for a disability reason you know
which employers should make adjustments
for Disabilities but demanding doctor's
notes is well the law doesn't actually
require that it's quite um quite
shocking and a lot of people say that
it's not in line with Google's values
you know Google used to say years ago
don't be evil and you know we consider
the way they're treating people in the
redundancy process to be quite evil and
you know that's why employees have taken
the decisions protest today okay and
briefly if you would please Matt uh
obviously Google is far from being alone
among the tech Giants in laying people
off are you building memberships in
other big employers right now the likes
of matter and Amazon
we are we are seeing growth yes um for a
long time you know the unions were
trying to grow in in the tech industry
and you know we are seeing some green
shoots of growth now because I think
people are realizing you know tech
companies
a lot of them have high values about how
they treat staff but
you're seeing yourself you're seeing
meta you're seeing Twitter the way you
know the way Twitter have threat their
employees people need an independent
voice at work and and they need some
independent support that they can access
and you can only really get that from a
trade Union all right Matt Whaley
appreciate you joining me today thank
you
no problem
our company law is stuck in a 40-year
Time Warp so says Archie Norman the
chairman of Marx and Spencer who in an
open letter to the business secretary
Kami badenok argues that ordinary people
who've invested in the UK's listed
businesses struggle to hear from and
communicate with them he argues the
situation could be changed by a handful
of straightforward amendments to the
company's Act
you can call me an old romantic if you
like but I still think that there's a
case for a share earning democracy no
one where individuals feel they've got a
stake in our big public companies and at
a time when trust in big business is on
the way in it's all the more important
that we like companies like marks and
Spencer are able to talk to our
individual shareholders directly
and I think the difficulty today is that
the law actually perversely prevents us
from doing so so we need to modernize
the way in which we talk to and
communicate with individual shareholders
so that we can contact them directly and
so that we can encourage people to have
a relationship with the companies that
are invested in now the heart of all
this is the nominee account where buy a
broker will hold a security on behalf of
their clients you think that is getting
in the way of the the relationship
between the company and its individual
shareholders
yeah so what's happened over the years
and this is over 30 or 40 years and
remember the companies act the company
law was really set in the 1980s revised
in 2006 and but what's happened in the
last 20 years is the way in which people
hold shares is through nominee accounts
through what they call platforms people
like Hargreaves Lansdowne and so those
platforms hold the shares on behalf of
the individual in what they call a
nominee account we as m s can't see who
the people are behind that nominee
account so we don't get to communicate
with them at all so whereas in the past
people apply or share and with knowers
you know Mrs Smith down in Clapham and
we'd write to her and could talk to her
directly and that now we can't even see
and if this goes on this way the current
rate in 30 years time m s will not have
a single individual shareholder we can
talk to
we're just going to break into our
interview with Archie Norman the
chairman of marks and Spencer don't
worry we will be bringing you that
interview in full later on in the
program we're just going to hear some
words from the Nitro Secretary General
Ian stoltenberg obviously Finland has
been admitted to Nato today
the Allies meet at The Summit in
villages later on allies will agree to
have a more ambitious defense investment
pledge where we regard two percent of
GDP for defense not as a ceiling but
that's the floor and minimum that we
need to spend in a more dangerous World
on our security
and then
we will also meet with our Asia Pacific
Partners New Zealand Australia Japan and
South Korea
security is not a regional Securities
Global what happens in Europe matters
for the indo-pacific for Asia and what
happens in Asia matters for Europe and
the war in Ukraine really demonstrate
start with all this Global ramifications
and also when we see that China and
Russia are coming more and more closely
that they stand together work to get
together it makes it even more obvious
that we need to stand together with
our partners in the Pacific
to take your questions
ready to bolster its presence around
Finland if NATO decided it's going to do
something sending more tricks this is
something that NATO's considering what
can we expect in coming weeks uh
months in terms of exercises and other
things that might be seen in this
attention
provocation well so first of all what
you have seen over many years is Russia
military buildup also in the north close
to Finland to Norway and this has taken
place over many years in the collapse in
Islam in the in the Arctic
and we have not only sea seen a Russian
military Builder but also seen that
Russia is a willing and President Putin
is willing to use military force against
neighbors Georgia in 2008 then Crimea in
2014 and then the full-fledged invasion
of Ukraine last year so this is part of
a pattern and that's exactly why we have
strengthened NATO our Readiness our
presence in the eastern part of the
Lions and why NATO allies are investing
more also new modern capabilities and it
was actually the invasion of Ukraine
last year that led to the decision by
Finland and Sweden to apply for a NATO
membership
and it just demonstrates that when
President Putin had US declared goal of
the invasion of Ukraine to get less NATO
he wanted less NATO along his borders he
wanted to close NATO store no more NATO
membership for any more countries in
Europe is getting exactly the opposite
he's getting more troops more redness
and more forces land sea and air
in the eastern part of the alliance and
he's getting more members Sweden today
and soon also
Finland today and soon also Sweden will
become a full-fledged member of the
alliance then we are constantly
assessing our posture our presence we
have more exercises we are more presence
on also in the Nordic area but but again
this is something which is partial
pattern that NATO has already responded
to
Mr stoneberg what does this mean
personally to you is this sort of an
emotional highlight for your term and
secondly can you really celebrate when
Sweden is not ready to join yet
so I'm glad and I'm proud to be the
Secretary General
um that can welcome Finland as a
full-fledged member of the alliance
this is important for NATO it's
important for Finland it's important at
least for the Nordic region and the
Baltic region you can just look at the
map and you stand how important Finland
is for the security in the Nordic and
the Baltic region and then also of
course Finland brings high-end
capabilities
substantial forces
and also the advanced defense industry
into the alliance
but personally I'm also not because I'm
from Norway I've worked with Finland and
Finnish politicians and leaders for many
many years and of course not so many
years ago we thought it was Unthinkable
that Finland would become a member now
they are a full-fledged member of our
alliance and that is truly historic and
uh and something that demonstrates that
Finland is a servant independent country
they make their own decisions and NATO
is an alliance of democracies with an
open door to democratic Seven Nations as
as Finland
will the security guarantees need to now
apply 100 to Finland and what will the
difference between killings
well what happens today is that Finland
becomes a full-fledged member of the
alliance and that means of course that
they will now participate fully as a
member in all NATO meetings activities
military structures command structure
and all parts of NATO uh civilian and
and Military structures but of course
most importantly is that by becoming a
member Finland will get an iron CAD
security guarantee Article 5 our
Collective defense laws One for All For
One well now from today apply for
Finland then of course this
is something that
uh Builds on what has happened over the
last year because when NATO allies when
the heads of state and government at The
Summit in Madrid in June austere decided
to invite Finland Sweden then both
Finland and Sweden came in a much
stronger and much better position
towards NATO than before
so also Sweden which is not yet a
full-fledged member uh it's in a very
close to a much better position as an
invitee they participate in NATO
meetings they are integrating into NATO
structures we are developing
KPD targets taking account for also
Sweden when we do defense planning so so
Sweden is also very close to Nato but of
course they haven't that final
ratification by all allies and therefore
another full-fledged member that was
hard on Sweden and you're actually also
had a question about is that of course
it is a great day to have Finland as a
member
but we will ensure that auto also Sweden
will become a full member and we have to
remember that all allies agreed to
invite them and all allies have signed
the accession protocol uh what remains
when it comes to Sweden is the
ratification in two parliaments I'm
confident that will happen uh I met with
President aduan so weaksu has also spoke
with him on the phone uh uh recently and
and and and and and we agreed uh of
course first of all to ensure that uh
Finland becomes a full member that the
accession process is now finalized for
Finland but we also agreed to restart
the process the meetings or the
permanent mechanism the meetings of
Finland Sweden and and turkey to ensure
us that we can make progress on the
ratification of uh of Sweden so Sweden
is in a much better place now than
before they applied and we will continue
to work hard to ensure that we can
finalize the ratification for the social
um
most of the countries in the eastern
Bank there are also troops from other
communities will there be food from
other countries also in Finland and the
second question how can Navy be more
safe
um
it is finished decision whether they
would like to have uh any uh there will
be no NATO troops in Finland without the
consent of uh of uh of Finland
um and of course what we have in many
countries is that we have exercises we
have a naval and uh and uh an air
presence and so on but we don't have
permanent basis and this has not been an
issue so far in our discussions with uh
with Finland
um
well um
the reality is that this is a result of
President Putin's
War regression against Ukraine
and of course Finland also has in
history that tells them about the
brutality uh that a war uh can afflict
on the country like the now see in
Ukraine and I like Finance all during
the the winter war in 1930 in 1914.
um and therefore when they saw that
President Putin didn't not only threaten
Ukraine but actually it threatened every
nation in Europe that wanted to make
their own decisions on joining Nate or
not then Finland decided to to join the
alliance
we will keep abreast of those comments
from Jen stoltenberg the NATO Secretary
General and bring those to you if
there's anything of import that is said
there in the meantime now we're going to
return to our interview with the Mox and
Spencer chairman Archie Norman who's
campaigning for an improvement to
shareholder democracy uh before uh we uh
cut out of the interview though I was
asking him whether he thought the
problems with nominee accounts could be
restored by uh establishing a link
between companies and shareholders via
the registrar here's what he told me
we think so I I the sensible thing is to
have a an industry platform or piece of
technology which simply means that all
the nominee accounts when you when you
register as a nominee account you
register an email address which unless
you opt out companies can communicate
you on and they can send you
annual report or notice as meetings or
just an update as to what's going on in
the company
now you also want digital Communications
to be enhanced between companies and
shareholders what sort of things do you
have in mind here
well at the moment by law again is it's
because the law is predates the digital
era almost all the communications we
send out are paper-based so a notice of
a meeting is paper-based the annual
report is paper-based and
the AGM is still by law meant to be held
physically so in a place so these old
Town Hall style ATMs are still mandated
in law what we're saying is look let's
open it up make companies accessible to
far more people by digitizing the
communications so we can email
if they really want to see annual report
that should be posted online they can
see it online we shouldn't have to send
it to them we can email notice some
meetings we can email opportunities to
do a
say a webcast with the chairman or chief
executive we can open up all these
things I mean to m s we find that we
have a what we call a small sharehold
apparel so we do invite our retail
shareholders in and we have a panel that
rotates every year and they come in to
meet with myself or the chief Executives
during Machin
and they love it and there's a huge list
of people who want to join the panel so
there's lots of appetite for this stuff
it's just we've made it very difficult
for people what is the cost to Marks and
Spencer of producing an annual report
and mailing it out
well so it's not just what people think
it's not just producing it
um I mean we employ a design firm to
design the cover
and uh you may or may not think is any
good but
um and then I write I draft a letter the
chief executive drafts the letter
there's a lot of management time goes
into this a huge amount of audit time
um so in total this is costing hundreds
of thousands of pounds I mean at a
minimum most ftse 100 type companies
will probably spend
a quarter million maybe half a million
every time we mail out to shareholders
that's over a hundred thousand pounds no
sentient Vision post and uh and the
annual reports now become of course
colossal documents I think you've got
one there do you want to hold that up so
the viewers can see the size of it I
want to show you I've I've actually
bought with me ten this is only 10
annual reports I don't know whether you
can see these are all big company annual
reports I can hardly lift it and I'll
show you the
this is the m s one from last year we're
just producing another one now there's
220 pages long lovingly produced and
full I have to tell you a very important
information that practically nobody's
ever read and
um we have to now my point is not that
we shouldn't produce it it's all well
intended but the reporting requirements
on companies have grown astronomically
so these are 48 longer on average than
they were five years ago and more than
double what they were 10 years ago so
my point is this is very few people read
these they're they're really only
interesting for investment analysts they
shouldn't be mailed out to to lots of
people
in this day and age they should be
posted online as they are and people
want to access them can review them
online
because
this is costing a lot of money it's
totally unsustainable I mean forests of
the world have been demolished a few
Sandy reports and it's very expensive to
do and takes a lot a lot of company time
and it's fundamentally they're not
suitable Communications for individual
shareholders there should be a different
form of communication to say to Mrs
Smith in Clapham this is the company
invested in this is how it's doing now
you also want to replace physical
meetings on occasions with digital
annual General meetings weren't that uh
covered a cost to society I mean is
isn't it vital for shareholder democracy
that's individual shareholders can come
along and look directors in the eye
well of course companies and Boards need
to be if they're held accountable this
is what we now this is our whole
argument is we do need to make boards
more accountable and more visibly
accountable and accessible to their
shareholders but this idea there's a an
old-fashioned town hall meeting
where people turn up take the day off
Trek down to London and turn up to us or
Stadium
and interrogate the board it is just
ridiculous I mean 30 40 years ago yes I
mean I remember going to the Asda AGM in
Pudsey Civic Hall in Leeds and there
were 800 angry Childers the share price
when I arrived or declined a long way
and that was a a testy feisty meeting
and served a purpose but that doesn't
happen anymore you know most
shareholders live in different parts of
the country long have gone are the days
when people will take a day off you know
if they're in work if they've got kids
to look after simply can't attend these
agms so the people who do attend tend to
be people who are typically retired
who've got the time available
and sometimes I you know we love them
all and there's some terrific people who
do turn up
but sometimes though quite a lot of
people too who like the sound of their
own voices rather too much and that
doesn't make for a great meeting
remember there's in a town hall AGM
typically you get through eight to ten
questions it's not really a test of the
board
um so what we're saying is look
at the moment by law you have to have a
physical meeting turn it into a digital
meeting open it up to the world know the
shareholders around the world in Marx
and Spencer who would like to attend
enable them to attend enable people in
Newcastle and lead and burn leads to
attend to take half an hour off work to
have a look into the AGM or time after
that day without having to travel to
London and and if you do that we can
show you that you get a much much better
result so
prior to the AGM we Health EMS prior to
the sorry pandemic we held the MS AGN in
Wembley Stadium not not in the stadium
itself I have to say but in a large room
there and we had about 500 odd no
wonderful people who turn up
quite a few of them pensioners and
people who m s pensioners former
employees and it was nice to see them
all but of course most of our
shareholders couldn't possibly come
during the pandemic we had to switch to
digital and there was an exemption
provided by the government to do so and
we've carried on with a primarily
digital AGM and last year we got 1 700
attending three times as many and then
you get a lot more people after the AGM
say well I couldn't attend on the day
but I'll have a watch a week later or a
week after so it sits on the record and
by the way
just in case you think it was all a big
fix and we were trying to avoid scrutiny
we invited
um Anita Anand to come we have a no we
invite some celebrity like herself here
to come and hold the ball to account and
they're the voice of the show so they
choose the questions we don't choose the
questions very good and we take live
questions so you know like this is how
things are done nowadays and all we're
saying is look if people really want to
hold a physical AGM fine we're not very
convinced by that because often you know
I've sat in agms where there's only two
or three shareholders in sometimes
they're held in locations which you have
to say quite difficult to get to yes and
you you just wonder what's going on we
think there should be a new framework
you should be encouraged to have a
digital AGM you should have encourage to
get big attendance because this is your
chance for people genuinely to to feel
they've got some content with the board
and it works very very well
well I can empathize with a lot of what
Archie Norman will say in that interview
there was one chairman uh who famously
used to hold his annual meetings on
Christmas Eve so he didn't have to face
the shareholders well Archie Norman uh
said a lot more to me and uh we'll be
playing out the rest of that interview
on this program this time tomorrow you
don't want to miss it in the meantime
we've got a bit more breaking news to uh
bring you're going to bring you an
update now on the news that the
professional boxer at Olympic medalist
damir Khan has been banned from All
Sport for two years after testing
positive for a prohibited substance he's
been speaking in the last few minutes
disguise Matthew Thompson
as well so I've got no comment at the
moment but I'll be in touch I'll give
you my verdict
does it does it mean that is it
essentially recognition that you cheated
in in the fight never I've never cheated
I'm a retired fighter and at the same
time
um
you can see by my performance
my performance against Kell Brook wasn't
the best performance artist so you sense
that you lost the fight I lost the fight
and obviously if I if I went in there
not kill Booker is different I've never
cheated my life I'm the one who wanted
the testing on on the fight and also
um
the amount look the amount that it was I
mean that was in my system could have
been by shaking people's hands and it
was I did it was a bodybuilding drug get
into your system that is the question
isn't it I don't know what I don't know
what what drug was in my system ostering
austrians so and at the same time I was
licensed for human consumption guys I'm
really sorry we need to prepare a
statement yeah I'll I'll be in touch I'm
gonna give myself My Views anyway but
like so I've never cheated in my life I
would never cheat Alexa I am a retired
fighter so I've got a two year by now
which is quite strange and funny that
they've run me I'm already so tired
anyway so no comeback plans then clearly
combat plans at all but like I said I've
never cheated
I was I mean I can't speaking
exclusively to Sky News I suspect he's
got a great deal more to say judging
from his comments there and we will of
course bring you those comments when we
get them
now almost half of the UK population is
currently not in a positive state of
mental well-being that is the finding of
a survey carried out for the insurance
giant AXA involving 30 000 people aged
18 to 74 from 16 countries across Europe
Asia and the Americas it found that some
21 of UK adults are in what the study
describes as emotional distress well the
estimated cost of this in terms of
working days lost as a result is put at
28 billion pounds we'll join him in our
life from Switzerland it's Claudia
Janelle he's the chief executive of AXA
UK and Ireland Claudio a very good
morning to you what was your motivation
for carrying out this study
morning in and thanks for having me here
so we it's the third year we do this and
the idea behind this is twofold one is
to make minor Health a theme that can be
talked about so only when we accept that
we have this in our society probably we
can do something about it and secondly
all the showing what an impact it has on
the economy and also what an important
role employers can have in helping the
employees to be in a good place mentally
when they come to work
what do you think the UK fared so
comparatively badly compared with its
peers
well no because on the good side uh we
had a better year than last year in the
UK we slightly have less people
struggling they've seen last year are
more people flourishing now compared to
the rest of the countries we look at
today is a piece which is positive where
people feel that there's less stigma
around mental health in the UK so people
are more open to talk about it and
secondly I do think we had two tough
years in the UK and that shows in the
numbers we have seen
a business is getting to grips with this
issue and uh supporting their employees
more
well I think what the numbers show is
it's quite dramatic where where
employees get support at the workplace
they are twice as likely to be happy or
two and a half times more likely to
flourish and the difference that you can
make as an employee is by having a
culture of trust respect and kindness
where people feel safe about being
themselves and everyone is struggling
and being able to say that work is key
to have a good mental health condition
and the second part is having tools uh
apps so example we have first mind
health supporters to detect people who
are distressed to help them and if you
do this I think there's a big play that
employees can have and it's not just the
employee himself or herself that feel
better it's they will be better with
their families in society in general so
it's it's helpful for everyone
now obviously you write health insurance
do you see many people increasing
numbers of people taking up the mental
health options
so we have seen an increase in in terms
of people asking for for help to when it
comes to mental health yes we have seen
that across the customer base too and I
think one of the things the study is of
the show is that women are more
struggling than men and especially young
ones I think that's the number that did
strike me most that 48 of all the people
between 18 and 24 we ask
um say they have a mental health
condition which is one in two that is
very interesting why do you think those
particular groups appear more vulnerable
well I think if you look at the young
ones it's quite well documented that
many of them have an addiction to Tech
the social networks
um so my weight is they don't spend
enough time in the here now accepting
that life sometimes is difficult
spending time with real friends real
family so when they struggle that they
have people can support them and and I
think in the eyes of the solution yeah
it's not uh
um something we can't address everyone
has in him on herself the force and that
what he needs to to look after yourself
but we need to take ourselves seriously
when it comes to mental health work on
it and spend time with ourselves to make
sure we're in a good State as we do
physically
and briefly if you would please Claudio
what sort of things are you doing within
AXA to support employees who come to you
when they they say they have this sort
of condition
so what we do we have what we call a
first AIDS when it comes to mental
health people who detect uh people who
are distressed that's a big piece so
that we can act when it happens but the
most important thing I believe we do
attacks a UK and Ireland is having a
culture uh that is built on trust
respect and kindness which gives this
fundament in the organization that
people can be themselves at work and
feel psychologically safe and that's the
biggest contribution I think we can make
as a company to make sure people have
the right the right environment when
they come to work and then secondly is
having tools that they can use yeah
all right Claudia I appreciate you
joining me today and thank you for being
so patient and waiting for us good to
see you this morning no problem thank
you and thanks for having me
still to come here only in King live
we're going to have a look at how the
markets are doing this Tuesday morning
don't go away
[Music]
foreign
thank you
[Music]
foreign
Welcome Matt let me tell you about some
of the other business news stories
around this morning and Sir Richard
Branson satellite launching firm virgin
orbit has filed for bankruptcy
protection and put itself up for sale
well the news comes just days after the
company said it was laying off around 85
of its 700 or 50 or so employees well
the future of Virgin orbit has been in
doubt since a failed attempt in January
to launch satellites from Cornwall with
its Flagship launcher one rocket the
rocket which is the first to be launched
from Britain failed to make it into
orbit and its payload of us and UK
satellite intelligence satellites ended
up in the ocean
the Cosmetics giant L'Oreal is buying
the Australian luxury Cosmetics group
Aesop for 2.5 billion US Dollars it's
the biggest deal done by the French
company in many years and the third
largest deal involving an Australian
company in the consumer goods sector
well ESOP which specializes in skin hair
and body care products was founded in
1987 and was bought outright by the
Brazilian company Natura whose other
assets include Avon and the body shop in
2016.
and the wealth manager's rathbones group
is merging with investec wealth and
investment the deal will create what the
pairs say will be the UK's leading
discretionary wealth manager with
approximately 100 billion pounds worth
of funds on the management and
administration well under the terms of
the deal which values invest at wealth
and investex investment at 839 million
pounds rathbones is issuing new shares
in itself to the division's parent
company investec the latter will then
own 41 and a quarter percent of the
enlarged rough bones
foreign
has Consolidated the gains it enjoyed
yesterday following the surprise
production cut announced by the OPEC
plus grouping on Sunday evening a barrel
of Brent crude will currently cost you
85.23 a barrel that's up a little over a
third of one percent on the equity
Market there was mixed trading in the
Asia Pacific region overnight there were
gains in Tokyo Shanghai Mumbai and in
Sydney but uh Hong Kong finished off
two-thirds of one percent we're in
Europe markets have continued the Bright
Start they made to the second quarter
there you are you can see all of the
main Continental European indices in
positive territory right now L'Oreal
which I mentioned a moment or so ago
eight Shares are up two-thirds of one
percent in Paris on news of that
acquisition well here in London the ftse
100 is also in positive territory
currently some eight points to the good
it's currently ahead right now for a
seventh consecutive session and that is
Led largely by The Mining and financial
stocks the leading Blue Chip Gainer this
morning is International Airlines group
the owner of course of British Airways
and erling us up one and three quarters
of a center on the back of some broker
comment but look at that it's actually
been overtaken for the footsie yellow
leader Jersey Now by glencore The Miner
up by just over two and a quarter
percent that is after it saw a 23
billion dollar offer that it made on
Monday for the Canadian minor Tech
resources get knocked back outside the
ftse 100 draft bones which are mentioned
a moment or so ago currently up by some
two percent on its acquisition of
investex wealth and investment arm
investec itself meanwhile up by three
and three quarter percent on the Foreign
Exchange Market well the pound earlier
this morning hit its highest level
against the US dollar since June last
year it's currently up some three
quarters of one percent against the
Greenback also half of one percent
higher against the Euro The single
currency meanwhile is up a third of one
percent right now against the dollar
joining me this morning is Michael
Metcalfe he's head of macro strategy at
State Street Michael good to see you
this morning let's start with FX because
there's a lot going on let's go to the
other side of the world first of all the
Reserve Bank of Australia didn't raise
interest rates overnight which obviously
hit the Aussie dollar but a very
interesting announcement I mean it was
and look obviously we're looking right
now for guidance from the central banks
because markets have been trying to
figure out where the peak in interest
rates are in in all countries to be
frank and the fact that the RBA kept
rates on hold might suggest that we've
finally reached a peak in Australia
already yeah and of course the Aussies
have raised interest rates I mean they
they moved more slowly than the bank of
England did but when they did get going
they really did and as prices have come
off a cliff almost haven't they yeah and
there's a group of economies where
obviously we need to watch the housing
market very closely Australia has won UK
obviously has won
um and Sweden is another and I think
look it's just a sign that higher rates
are doing their job and slowing the
economy and that might mean that rates
don't need to go up anymore what about
this strength in Sterling now it looks
as though there's a bit of dollar
weakness attached to it but nonetheless
the pound is is broadly ahead across a
range of currencies today is this the
market starting to think that after the
inflation numbers last week the bank may
have to go again yeah well look it's
really interesting that Sterling is
reacting positively to things like uh
you know expectations of higher rates
and higher inflation because I think
certainly three or four months ago
Sterling was suffering from a bit of a
credibility problem you know those
questions about credibility of policy
both on the monetary side and the fiscal
side I think and I think that that is
now going away and I think confidence to
the pound is returning now looking at
the equity markets obviously uh Europe
in the pink this morning likewise London
I'm quite surprised by this given this
OPEC production cup that we've had I
mean implicit in all that is higher
inflation not necessarily good news I
mean look obviously higher inflation
would be really bad news right now
because it would mean that we were not
at the peak in rates but it does seem to
be that Equity markets are showing a
little bit of underlying resilience you
know we got through all those shocks in
the first quarter uh second quarter we
thought we'd done with the shocks but
obviously OPEC threw another one in
there so the fact that equities have
continued to Rally even though all
prices have gone up I think it suggests
underlying sentiment is is pretty firm I
mean obviously the ftse is heavy in all
stocks but Continental Europe perhaps
less so is this really a reflection of
the fact that the earnings season we've
just gone through was better than
expected well look I mean this is the
thing you know at the start of the Year
everyone was predicting recession and
suggesting that earnings would come down
and actually the macro data has
suggested maybe the recession risks are
a little bit lower and as you say
earnings so far so far so good so yeah
and also this huge rally in tech stocks
that we've seen in the US over the last
quarter well I mean again it's
interesting all the shocks that we had
in the first quarter Tech is still seen
as something of a safe haven I think the
only risk there obviously is that we do
need to get it this idea that we've
reached the peak in rates in the US for
Tech to continue to perform all right
Michael we've got to leave it there I'm
afraid great to see you this morning
thank you
uh our entertainment venues visitor
attractions and theme parks compete for
business offering a better service to
customers is more important than ever
whether that's enabling them to buy food
and drink more easily get a parking pass
in advance or joining a virtual queue
well aim listed accesso technology
provides software enabling uses for the
Leisure entertainment and cultural
sectors this morning it reported a full
year pre-tax profit of 12.4 million
dollars for 2022 that was up two and a
half percent on 2021 will join him in
our accessories chief executive Steve
Brown now Steve welcome to you thanks
very much for joining me at such an
unsociable hour your time which are the
applications most in demand right now
from customers
well we see demand across all our
Solutions but online ticketing mobile
ticketing is is clearly
um you know at a new level of demand as
consumers look for self-service venues
look for utilizing less labor to sell
tickets but also demand for virtual
queuing um you know people seem to have
uh little patience for waiting in a
queue these days so both are premium
queuing and our e-commerce products are
leading the way
now you're in 29 countries worldwide I
would assume given the strength of its
economy night right now that the US is
the most exciting for you
the U.S is exciting um what's
interesting is that we're seeing demand
across the Leisure sector in all the
geographies that we serve people are
looking to get out and have fun and uh
you know
facilitate that in the easiest way
possible which is typically from their
mobile phone on all fronts whether
they're ordering food and beverage or
buying a ticket or finding a way to you
know avoid waiting in the queue
um the U.S is certainly doing very well
but we're seeing strength across all the
regions where we operate
your career began at Disney of course a
Leisure and theme park industry been
quick enough to adopt technology of this
kind
you know actually it's a very good point
I don't think so
um I think the scale
um the priority around you know the
attractions the entertainment often
consumes Capital before technology does
but we're seeing a significant catch up
on that over the past few years
um you know driven by consumer demand
you know people's desire to do things on
their own use their mobile device but
also on the operator side the need to
operate with less labor but also to
manage with less available labor so the
operators have this demand and the
consumer have the demand and the two
worlds are sort of colliding um in terms
of
um you know how they how the uh
technology has prioritized in terms of
capital spending and focus by the
leadership of these different venues now
the Leisure industry has obviously gone
through an enormous amount of upheaval
in recent years with the pandemic I just
wonder how you're positioning yourself
for the future
you know things are back to normal I
have to say better than normal to be
honest we're seeing demand at levels we
saw um we didn't even see before the
pandemic so you know we're really
focused on just continuing to provide
the technology options for these venues
as they look to modernize their
modernize their platforms and provide
technology in new ways like mobile food
and beverage
um ordering which now has become
commonplace in theme parks or even the
local McDonald's you know that you may
walk into it's self-service ordering
it's kiosk
um you know the days of manual labor are
passing and it's all about mobile
Commerce going forward and we are
working very hard to make sure we can
meet those demands
now it's worth pointing out I guess uh
you don't just have customers in the
Leisure sector one of your other clients
is the Irish Defense Forces tell me
about that
that's right you know we have a we have
a product called a prism which is a
device we use in Virtual queuing in
locations where your mobile to phone
your mobile phone isn't as um conducive
like a water park
um where you want to leave that in the
locker and go about and have fun but uh
during uh during the pandemic we did a
pilot project with the Irish defense
fund to allow them to provide some
tracking and information for um their
military staff because the device has
great tracking capabilities for social
distancing
um and the whereabouts relative to other
people so that's just an example of some
of the Innovation that happens outside
of what you might expect from excessive
all right Steve we've got to leave it
there I'm afraid thanks very much indeed
for joining me again and as I said such
an unsociable I appreciate it thank you
now the funding environment for startups
has not been too healthy over the last
six months and we're certainly hearing a
lot less about so-called unicorns those
are privately held startup companies
that have achieved a value of more than
a billion dollars but that is exactly
what the British data analytics company
contacts are has just achieved the
company whose AI powered software helps
Financial companies fight fraud and
financial crime has just raised 129
million dollars in its series e-rand
that values it at 1.8 billion dollars
and confirms its Unicorn State as well
joining me now is the chief executive of
contexter Vishal Maria Vishal very good
to see you again we last had you on the
program in October 2021 have you traded
since then thank you for having me on
today uh Ian from a business standpoint
um we've doubled in all metrics if
that's around revenues if that's around
number of customers or clients we're
servicing globally but also the number
of users we've gone from about six seven
thousand to over 12 000 end users on our
platform so it's been an incredible
journey
um and plenty more to do I mentioned
Financial or Services there that is not
the only egg you have in the basket as
it were no absolutely Ian and so when I
started contexter back in 2016 I still
remind myself it's only been seven years
um the strategy was very much a
multi-industry strategy so to support
Banks insurers but also the public
sector and we were delighted to be
awarded the contract earlier this year
by the cabinet office but we're also
working in telecommunications and and
other Industries as well yeah this
cabinet office uh contract is quite a
big deal for you what does that entail
so if you imagine from a financial crime
in a fraud perspective there's a lot of
data elements out there
and if that's around bank account
information if that's around application
data
um every fraudster leaves a footprint
and that footprint is in the data so
what we're doing for many of our clients
is how do you Stitch that data together
to unify it and then apply the best of
machine learning in AI on top of that
Consolidated view on top of that unified
view that's what we call decision
intelligence and we're doing this for
many of our clients today so tell me
about the funding round I mean I gather
you haven't got through all of the
capital you raised at your last round
were you actually looking to raise money
right now so great great question Ian so
when we close series D which again was
summer of 21 which was led by uh Warburg
Pincus and during the process of the
last sort of 12 18 months as part of our
duties we spend time with many investors
some of those investors who gave me term
sheets in 21 but also new parties so
every quarter we've been having
conversations and you know showing
predictability show going to the market
that you know I say we're going to do
this by June and we do it I'll say we're
going to do this by October and we do it
it's been a great great journey on that
point and so coming to the beginning of
this year we started getting a lot of
inbound and a lot of investors looking
at what we're saying looking at the
market we're servicing and we started
receiving inbound so we then kicked off
quite a robust process
um earlier this year and I'm delighted
to onboard GIC to my cap table they've
been a an absolute pleasure through the
Journey and I look forward to the
journey with them and what is this going
to enable you to do this this injection
of capital great uh Ian so one thing is
really important for context is when I
started it was to build foundational
Tech foundational Tech here in the UK
that hasn't changed and the operating
plan I've put together for the next
three to five years for contexter is not
changed which is going to see us to get
to a path to profitability and so we're
aiming to be profitable in 2025 which
again for a company of our age growing
up 80 90 to get to profitability it's a
huge kudos to the market a huge kudos to
my clients so that won't change but what
we now have is opportunity even more
opportunity if that's organic so looking
at innovation in the platform we have
built verticalizing the platform even
more but also inorganic so we
successfully acquired our first business
in February and there's more
opportunities ahead good stuff Fisher
it's nice to see you again in the studio
thanks for joining me
[Music]
time for a look now at this morning's
business pages and the financial times
leads its print edition with news at ey
has been banned from taking on any new
listed audit clients in Germany for two
years over failures in its work for the
collapsed payments company wire card the
ft is currently leading its Digital
Editions meanwhile with news at the
National Crime agency has dropped two of
three lines of inquiry against the
sanctioned Russian billiard Mikhail
Friedman after his arrest in December
there is also extensive coverage of the
life and career of the former Chancellor
Lord Lawson the Ft quotes law of Nick
McPherson the former treasury permanent
secretary as saying Lawson was one of
the greatest chancellors of the 20th
century
well Lord Lawson also appears on the
front page of the times it's business
Pages meanwhile lead with yesterday's
surgeon oil prices on the back of a
surprise OPEC production cut meanwhile
The Daily Telegraph which also splashes
with laws Lawson's death leads its
business pages with reports that
bickering and Brussels is threatening to
inflict cues and disruption on British
holiday makers for years to come by
derailing the rollout of new technology
that would speed up passport checks or
joining me this morning is Oliver Shaw
associate editor at the Sunday Times
Ollie good to see you this morning
um Lord Lawson I think really is without
dispute a giant of the late 20th century
uh economics scene isn't he he really is
and he's the cognizant his choice of
Tory pinup isn't he if Maggie Thatcher
is the conservative leader or prime
minister's low back to uh Nigel Lawson
is the chancellor uh Tory Chancellor
tend to hark back to enrichi sunak
famously had a picture of Lawson above
his desk in the treasury he's the tax
cutting Chancellor remembers for um loan
top rate 40 and in the late 80s he was
indeed but the key point which I think
Liz truss and quasi quatteng forgot was
that you actually have to get the public
finances in order before you start
cutting taxes it's very true the pointer
Richie sack made in his May's lecture at
City University a few years ago you have
to as you say earn the right to cut
taxes by building up a strong economy
and um people also forget you know he's
a member of that rah-rah budgie it's
where it was all sort of boom boom boom
1988 but um the Lawson boom then led to
some of the uh inflation and economic
pain of the early 90s didn't this so it
was not an unbridled good thing yeah but
the other thing that people often forget
he was a tax simplifier I mean he always
said taxes work best when they're simple
low and fair and if you look at what's
happened to the tax code since I
complicated it's got he had a point yeah
you wonder what he would make of uh
various windfall taxes right now at a
time when we're trying to attract
investment in their Renewables and uh
energy and things like the convoluted
raising of corporation tax with the
addition of various incentives it's not
very
because of course he fell out with Mrs
Thatcher famously over ERM membership
but he later became a brexiteer yes
funny combination isn't I mean he
thought the ERM would uh stabilize
inflation in the UK and stabilize Sterly
obviously that was not exactly the
the outcome but um you're right he had a
late late life swing to the right didn't
he and there was a vigorous campaigner
for brexit and um claimed I think some
responsibility for pushing Cameron into
calling the uh referendum yeah and also
famously he very uh he endorsed Rishi
sunak during the original leadership
contest when he was up against uh Liz
trust perhaps he knew a thing or two
there yeah I think Rishi sunak um
idolizing Lawson as he did went and paid
homage to Lawson and France and um he
was clearly a very keen follower of
Lawsons and did study his books pretty
closely as per the whole thing around
you can't sort of just cut taxes off the
hoof you have to get there and that cost
him the initial leadership didn't they
yeah really did I mean it's just
extraordinary stuff I mean if if you
think about back to Lawson as well I
mean he was also one of the real drivers
of privatization
yeah I mean he along with Margaret
Thatcher were the two main uh
intellectual powerhouses of that
government weren't they and um the tell
Sid campaigns around British gas uh BP
these kind of companies he was a key
driver of them yeah which is funny
enough what I've been talking to Archie
Norman about uh this one do you think
Archie's got a point here with this
campaign to enhance shareholder
democracy uh yes and no I think um the
idea of digital agms is good and well
but I think you still need the
traditional AGM there's something about
the Democracy isn't there of management
teams being held to account physically
having to go somewhere once a year and
Archie uh chairing m s the
quintessential uh prawn sandwich AGM uh
purvey I should know that but I think
his other points around um nominee
companies is very good all right Ollie
good to see you this morning thank you
that's it from me I'm back at 10 o'clock
tomorrow morning with more from Archie
Norman you don't want to miss it in the
meantime do stay tuned after this short
break it's Kimberly Leonard thanks for
joining me today cheerio
[Music]
foreign